okay when we're done we believe that we
will have made the case overwhelmingly
of the president's guilt that is he's
done what he's charged with he withheld
the money he withheld the meeting he
used it to coerce Ukraine to do these
political investigations he covered it
up he obstructed us he's trying to
obstruct you and he's violated the
Constitution but I want to address one
other thing tonight
okay he's guilty
okay he's guilty does he really need to
be removed does he really need to be
removed we have an election coming up
does he really need to be removed he's
guilty you know is there really any
doubt about this I mean do we really
have any doubt about the facts here does
anybody really question whether the
president is capable of what he's
charged with
no one is really making the argument
Donald Trump would never do such a thing
because of course we know that he would
and of course we know that he did it's a
somewhat different question though to
ask okay it's pretty obvious whether we
can say it publicly or we can't say it
publicly we all know what we're dealing
here with this president but does he
really need to be removed and this is
why he needs to be removed Donald Trump
chose Rudy Giuliani over his own
intelligence agencies
he chose Rudy Giuliani over his own FBI
director he chose Rudy Giuliani over his
own national security advisors when all
of them were telling him this Ukraine
2016 stuff is kooky crazy Russian
propaganda he chose not to believe them
he chose to believe Rudy Giuliani that
makes him dangerous to us to our country
that was Donald Trump's choice now why
would Donald Trump believe a man like
Rudy Giuliani over a man like
Christopher Rea okay why would anyone in
their right mind believe Rudy Giuliani
over Christopher Rea because he wanted
to and because what Rudy was offering
him was something that would help him
personally and what Christopher a was
offering him was merely the truth what
Christopher Rea was offering him was
merely the information he needed to
protect his country and its elections
but that's not good enough
what's in it for him what's in it for
Donald Trump this is why he needs to be
removed now you may be asking how much
damage can he really do in the next
several months until the election a lot
a lot of damage now we just saw last
week report that Russia tried to hack or
maybe did hack burr yzma okay I don't
know if they got in I'm trying to find
out my colleagues are on the Intel
committee House and Senate we're trying
to find out did the Russians get in what
are the Russian plans and intentions
well let's say they got in and let's say
they start dumping documents to
interfere or the next election let's say
they start dumping some real things they
hack from Burr yzma let's say they start
dumping some fake things they didn't
hack from Burr yzma but they want you to
believe they did let's say they start
blatantly interfering in our election
again to help Donald Trump can you have
the least bit of confidence that Donald
Trump will stand up to them and protect
our national interest over his own
personal interest you know you can't
which makes him dangerous to this
country you know you can't
you know you can't count on him none of
us can none of us can what happens if
China got the message now you can say
well he's just joking of course he
didn't really mean China should
investigate the binds you know that's no
joke
now maybe you could have argued three
years ago when he said hey Russia if
you're listening hack Hillary's emails
maybe you could give him a freebie and
say he was joking but now we know better
hours after he did that Russia did in
fact try to hack Hillary's emails
there's no Mulligan here when it comes
to our national security so what if
China does overtly or covertly start to
help the Trump campaign you think he's
going to call him out on it or you think
he's going to give him a better trade
deal on it can any of us really have the
confidence that Donald Trump will put
his personal interests ahead of the
national interest is there really any
evidence in this presidency that should
give us the ironclad confidence that he
would do so you know you can't count on
him to do that that's the sad truth you
know you can't count on him to do that
the American people deserve a president
they can count on to put their interest
first to put their interest first
Colonel van Minh said here right matters
here right matters well let me tell you
something
if right doesn't matter if right doesn't
matter it doesn't matter how good the
Constitution is it doesn't matter how
brilliant the framers were it doesn't
matter how good or bad our advocacy in
this trial is doesn't matter how
well-written the oath of impartiality is
if right doesn't matter we're lost if
the truth doesn't matter we're lost the
framers couldn't protect us from
ourselves if right and truth don't
matter and you know that what he did was
not right you know that's what they do
in the old country
the colonel ven-ven's father came from
or the old country that my
great-grandfather came from or the old
countries that your ancestors came from
or maybe you came from but here right is
supposed to matter it's what's made us
the greatest nation on earth no
Constitution can protect us right
doesn't matter anymore and you know you
can't trust this president do what's
right for this country you can trust he
will do what's right for Donald Trump
he'll do it now he's done it before
he'll do it for the next several months
he'll do it in the election if he's
allowed to this is why if you find him
guilty you must find that he should be
removed because right matters because
right matters
and the truth matters otherwise we are
lost Wow holy Sh
you